cloud vision provides powerful image
analytics capabilities as easy-to-use
api's enables application developers to
build the next generation of application
that can see and understand the content
within the images the service is built
on powerful computer vision models that
power several to bring Google services
the service enables developers to detect
a broad set of entities within an image
from everyday objects to faces and
product logos the service is so easy to
use as one example of the use cases you
can't have any Raspberry Pi robot like
gulp I go calling the cloud vision API
directly so the bot can send the images
taken by its camera to the cloud and can
get the analysis result in real time it
detects faces in the image along with
the associated emotions the cloud vision
API is also able to detect entities
within the image now let's see how
facial detection works cloud vision
detect spaces on the picture and returns
the positions of eyes nose and mouth so
you can program the bots to follow the
face it also detects emotions such as
joy anger surprise and sorrow so the bot
can move toward smiling faces or avoid
anger or surprise face one of the very
interesting features of cloud vision API
is the entity detection that means it
detects any objects you like see how it
works
it's glasses you see cloud visions let's
developers to take advantage of Google's
latest machine learning technologies
quite easily please go to cloud
google.com slash vision to learn more